6 25 on your friday morning what's
driving me crazy how about a mountain
marathon that's going to affect that
area around the 95 and the 215 so let's
go
centennial bowling
yeah not too far away from where the 95
meets the 215 there's an event called
the revel
mount charleston limited edition it's a
two-day event it's today and tomorrow
from five in the morning till three in
the afternoon now it's mainly affecting
state highway 157 kyle canyon road but
both the half marathon and the full
marathon also tying up drivers on oso
blanca from sky point a sky canyon that
is
up to the 157 also affecting fort apache
from grand teton down to centennial
parkway
durango from centennial parkway down to
grand montecito so the nevada department
of transportation says hey there will be
a pilot car
up on kyle canyon road and the drivers
should expect delays of up to 20 minutes
on the mountain
race organizers limiting participation
to 250 runners
groups of more than 50 for social
distancing good luck to the runners on
this tough higher elevation event
a reminder to drivers be extra vigilant
in the areas around the races there are
detailed maps of both the races on the
website www.runrevel.com but
we've got a link to that on our website
eightnewsnow.com click traffic and then
driving you crazy buckle up drive
carefully please put down the phone
if there's something driving you crazy
email me traffic 8 8newsnow.com